the joggin experience what do you think
of I'm looking forward to our to Sonya I
kind of wanted to see Paulo cos to get
the fight but I I'm the fact that he's
doing with Romero is still it's still a
great fight I'm happy it's you Oh Romero
for two reasons one because Paul cost
they can do in the future the Holocaust
is only like twenty nine years old he's
a young guy just like Adesanya
and too stylistically I want to see I
still want to see Paul Acosta I mean
Paul Costa is a monster man he's he's a
monster
I'm really I mean especially after a
beol like that really interested in
seeing him fight Israel but
stylistically I'm interested in Yoel
Romero vs Israel because of the
wrestling because yo Elle's wrestling is
crazy he's one of the most powerful guys
that's ever fought in that division he's
enormous for that division and he's so
[ __ ] explosive and he can take it
credible and crazy shot I mean if you
look at the two of them together yeah I
mean is he is taller and longer and Yoel
is just [ __ ] jacked he's not even
built like a real human his waist is
this tiny thing his muscles are [ __ ]
preposterous when you see him you're
like oh that's a comic book guy that's
not a real person he's a comic book
person he's 40 years old 41 years old
he's 41 still jacked super super jacked
and I think honestly he should have
already been the champion I think he
beat Robert Whittaker in the second
fight my feeling is that he heard him
more he was more effective and there was
two rounds that easily could have been
ten eight rounds where he had Robert
Whittaker [ __ ] staggered and if that
was the case he would have won the title
if he was it a split decision I don't
remember I don't know I don't remember
you google Yoel Romero versus Robert
Whittaker I don't know I mean split
decisions are so crazy right it's like
what if Thiago Santos is the UFC light
heavyweight champion now because one
judge says he should be two judges say
he isn't split decisions are real weird
I think there's not enough judges there
should be at least five judges it
probably should be ten and I think we
should also have an online judging I
think they should have that and maybe
they don't take it into consideration in
term but but for us was this a year
unanimous unanimous decision what by one
point on each judges scorecard and I
disagreed with that but you know that's
okay
very interesting
yeah I'm looking forward to that I don't
remember when the fight is but I'm
looking forward to it yeah that's all
when is that when is Izzie oil is that
March in Vegas
I think it's yes it yeah March is I
think is and what you're thinking
because in Brooklyn right yes you going
to that I don't know it depends if I'm
working that we take that weekend off
Jamie I got a bunch of dates I'm not now
up so I may be I may be working I don't
remember I'm super pumped for Dominic
Rhea's and John Jones yes that is a
dangerous fight for Jon Jones Dominic
Reyes he is not getting enough credit
he's 12 and oh he has a [ __ ] a
ruthless left hand he's super athletic
and he's really tall he's really tall
and long and he's a young guy he's 30
years old you know and John you know
John has to take that guy really [ __ ]
seriously I did think if I remember
correctly I remember thinking it was
Damir won the fight I thought it was to
me god I thought he should have gotten a
decision over Domino Reyes yeah really
close yeah look at that stats again the
the tale of the tape Jamie look at the
difference in the reach John Jones has
an eighty three and a half eighty four
and a half inch reach and then you look
at Dominic Reyes is 77 that's
interesting that's the width of the
shoulders John is so long yeah you know
you're measuring tip to tip like this
and one thing that John excels at is
keeping people at distance but he's
fighting a guy that's his height that
guy's just as long as him maybe not as
wide obviously the reach is different in
terms of the width of the shoulders but
Dominic Cruz's footwork and movement is
excellent as kicks or excellent
he's got nasty power in his hands and
he's got a lot of confidence man he's
undefeated coming in at 12 and oh that
guy is a killer well he did to Chris
Weidman I was like holy [ __ ] yeah I was
a rougher to watch it's hard to watch
was that am I crazy to think that
Gustafson had that kind of reach - yes
he did right he was close - closer to
Jones - most guys Gustafson although he
has fantastic combinations in excellent
boxing does not have one
punch power the way Dominic Reyes has
right Dominic Reyes sets things up and
when he moves in boom he drops things on
you and dudes fold like when he fought
OSP he knocked out OSP with no time in
the fight it was basically like a couple
of seconds to go in the fight he cracked
OSP and they didn't give him the
knockout which I don't understand he
mean it was way worse than Alistar and
and Rosen strike I mean he he had OSP
out he was gone and they they didn't
stop the fight and I'm like I don't
understand this this is like it was
confusing to me because he walked away
like it was over and it looked see if he
could find that Dominic Reyes drops OSP
who was winning the fight at that point
da McRae as well but OSP gave him some
trouble he gave him some trouble what I
mean Dominic was definitely winning the
fight but OSP had his moments definitely
had his moments in and I watched that
fight about a month ago or so and when I
was watching I was trying to find
moments where I think John could
capitalize that OSP couldn't but OSP is
this trust very strong guy he's just a
lot of guys struggle with him including
John Jones John Jones struggled with OSP
it's a powerhouse man you can't [ __ ] up
with OSP you know he kikyo's guys he can
kale people with one punch like he
killed Shogun with one punch
he killed Corey Anderson I think wasn't
and I think that was John's first fight
back after a while he taking that layoff
and I was his first fight back after a
suspension or he had been gone for a
while
and they had no one thought that I was
choosing to go the distance I didn't it
didn't they go five and get the decision
yep they did so here it is so here's
Dominic Reyes what's this
he's moving boom he drops him look at
that he's out look at that he's just
lying there out and Dominic Reyes moves
off like that's it and they don't stop
the fight and the referee stands over
and lets him get back up to his feet in
the bell rang and they didn't call it a
knockout I'm like okay that's a knockout
man you could you know you couldn't
justify keeping that fight going but
that's what I bet you Overeem wishes
would have happened was that they would
let it just walk away
100% and that if listen if Dan murgh
leotta and Dan did his job because Dan
supposed to be the guy that calls the
fight right I think he should have
called the fight but Dan
is supposed to be the guy that calls the
fight not the fighter so when Dominic
played it again when Dominic caio's him
all he had to do was follow up with a
couple strikes and then the [ __ ]
show's over watch this but it's
beautiful footwork I love how he did it
- so OSP is moving because he's behind
so he's trying to move forward and press
and trying to catch him
and Dominic's move in and OSB presses
him and you know and he uses good
footwork to avoid this - it catches that
left kick which is osp's power side and
as OSP is setting it up you see go
southpaw again so he's looking for that
left kick again there it is boom counter
took step over bang left hand and then
referees waiting for him to follow up so
if he just jumped on him there and
followed up instead of walking his hands
up the buzzer may have gone off
somewhere around then I don't know when
the buzzer went off yeah I was like 20
seconds 21 seconds when he hit up yeah
but Stern account Danberg see if we can
get some volume on that oh no it's a lot
less than that yeah lot less
so right at the horn so he dropped him
at the horn I still think they should
have stopped it but I don't know
whatever he won the fight but look he
basically knocked him out with a second
yeah
[Applause]